almost a quarter of a million women are
diagnosed with ovarian cancer each year
more than half will die within five
years of their diagnosis most died
because their cancer develops resistance
to the most common form of treatment
platinum-based chemotherapy most
patients respond well to treatment at
first but many relapse within 18 months
eventually almost all patients will
relapse with a tumor that has developed
resistance to platinum based therapy the
treatment works by damaging the DNA of
cancer cells in a way that triggers
programmed cell death a process known as
apoptosis
but Platinum resistant tumor cells use a
variety of tricks to fight back some
cells learn to repair damaged DNA other
cells pump the Platinum out before it
does any damage researchers are trying
to find ways to overcome this resistance
one approach is to block the mechanisms
that cells use to fix the NA damaged
with drugs such as PARP inhibitors
another drug called trevecca din binds
to DNA and damages it directly a second
approach is to target the tumors blood
supply rather than the tumor itself
drugs can be used to prevent the growth
of blood vessels in and around the tumor
starving it and stunting its growth
researchers also hoped to recalibrate
the immune system to overcome platinum
resistance and vaccine trials are
already underway aimed at priming immune
cells to recognize and attack cancer
cells after decades of limited
improvement there is finally a sense of
optimism our growing understanding of
ovarian cancer and the mechanisms of its
resistance to treatment may soon be
translated into real benefits for pay
you